whatever it takes whatever it takes
[Music]
heretics
whatever it takes hey everybody its
charlie there's a brand new Thanos
preview for Avengers endgame that we
have to break down and you've had a
whole bunch of WTF questions about
Captain Marvel so I added that to this
to we'll talk about that us then we'll
talk about Captain Marvel stuff the IMAX
ticket giveaway is still going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your biggest
Avengers endgame questions on the video
you notice that Thanos is finally
wearing his full suit of armor for those
of you that were disappointed that he
did not fight them in his armor during
Avengers infinity war he has the
Infinity Gauntlet his arm isn't all
mangled the gauntlet isn't partially
melted all six Infinity stones look
perfect it's as if he completely healed
his arm and repaired all the damage to
the gauntlets since the end of Avengers
infinity war whereas a lot of websites
are probably incorrectly speculating
they travel back in time and that's why
it's a perfect gauntlet because in
present day it's still all messed up
what I really think is going on with
this is that they made it look like this
all nice and shiny for the magazine
cover this is purposefully being
inaccurate and making him look perfect
because they were worried that showing
Thanos with a mangled arm and a
partially melted gauntlet would scare
people away from buying the magazine
like put something really horrific on
the cover and people won't buy as many
of the magazines I don't think that they
put him on the cover here to give you a
hot scoop about Thanos during Avengers
endgame I think they just put him here
to sell more magazines based on the
Captain Marvel footage and the other new
scenes of that first Thanos rematch
during the Avengers end game trailer
with cap and nebula rocket Rhodey it's
more likely that their early plan right
after Captain Marvel arrives like you
have this scene here with her stand up
with Thor is that they go straight for
Thanos that happens pretty early in the
movie I did a video for those extra
Captain Marvel battle planning scenes
last week they screamed at a different
Disney investors meeting there was a
whole bunch of extra footage I'll link
that video at the end of this but during
those scenes this smaller group of
Avengers like everybody isn't here they
decide to go find Thanos on his new
version of Titan that he created at the
end of Infinity Ward the ruse was just
call it tightened to his farm here they
fight him there but they don't have Thor
Iron Man or the Hulk and it's pretty
clear from the Captain America footage
that they lose and they lose hard so
when they would be fighting him there
the gauntlet would still be melted his
arm would still be messed up but he
still
has all six Infinity stones and he can
still use the Infinity Gauntlet Annie's
had all these months or however many
weeks it's been since the snap to
perfect how he can use it the Russos
explained during Infinity Ward there's a
certain learning curve with using each
of the different Infinity stones powers
in combination with each other if you
watch the commentary for Infinity Ward
during the fight on Titan the rousseau
say that you can see fan oohs learning
how to use the Infinity stones while
he's fighting them so by the end of that
fight he's way more proficient in using
the gauntlet than he was at the
beginning so if it took him less than a
couple of days to figure out how to snap
everyone using all six stones in
combination then think about how much
better he is using it later in the
timeline when they come back to fight
him again for the first time based on
the way that the quantum realm and
quantum energy is so important to the
Avengers fixing everything ultimately by
the end of Avengers endgame there's a
theory that early in the movie one of
fan OSes measures of last resort is to
destroy the affinity gauntlet in present
day so that the Avengers can't do the
exact same thing that they did during
the first movie and just try and steal
it right off of his hand that would
actually be a pretty smart way to go
after him just try to get the gauntlet
and unsnap everyone so the easiest way
fans could prevent that from happening
is to destroy the gauntlet himself but
hopefully that explains what's going on
with Thanos yes he will wear his full
suit of armor that's why they show it to
you on the Scarecrow during the Avengers
end game trailer they just want to let
you know that it's still around still
gonna be a big thing but yeah his arm is
still super messed up in the gauntlet is
still kind of melty there were a lot of
WTF questions about Captain Marvel after
the Captain Marvel movie in Captain
Marvel during Avengers endgame like
what's she gonna be doing what are they
gonna use her for so this is a top 10
that I broke down careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the Captain Marvel
movie starting with number 10 what is
Captain Marvel's weakness she's super
powerful that's great but it creates a
lot of story problems when a character
has no weaknesses Kevin Feige confirmed
this after the movie came out he said
that she does have a weakness but for
the purposes of the Captain Marvel movie
what they wanted to do at the end of
that was just show her Unchained so you
won't actually see her weaknesses till
avengers endgame so it gives him a
really surprised twist for avengers
endgame when she isn't so powerful
against Thanos if you're not familiar
with how her powers
work in the comics she absorbs energy
that's how she goes into binary form
being in binary form drains that power
very quickly so the only way for her to
maintain that level of power is to
continually absorb energy at a great
enough level when her energy levels are
much lower
she's much weaker if she were to fight
Thanos as long as Thanos didn't blast
her with enough energy that she could
absorb and just use physical damage like
literally just pounded her he could
block a lot of her attacks and then
eventually just wear her down number 9
what happened to the supreme
intelligence in the last 20 years it's
artificial intelligence in the movie
which makes it functionally immortal so
unless someone like Galactus completely
cold their homeworld it's probably still
alive still hates Captain Marvel and is
still plotting other ways to enhance the
Kree race in swerd captain Marvel's
attempts to pacify their part of the
galaxy because that's what she's been
doing for the last 20 years trying to
stop the kree-skrull war do not be
surprised if the supreme intelligence
comes back during the Captain Marvel
sequel I do not expect to see it during
avengers endgame though that would be a
big surprise number 8 why did Nick Fury
use the shield acronym in the 90s when
Coulson didn't use it till the events of
the Iron Man movies after 2008 they made
a whole joke during the movie about the
full title being super long now you
really need to find a way to shorten
that yeah we're working on it I'm agent
Phil Coulson with the strategic homeland
intervention enforcement and logistics
division that's quite a mouthful I know
we're working on it Agent Coulson oh
yeah the guy from the strategic homeland
intervention right mystics division
I get a new name for that yeah the way I
explain this is that Coulson at that
time was just being overly formal with
pepper and iron man and within the
organization people just unofficially
refer to it as shield so it'd be like
someone using your formal name and then
using a contraction like my real name is
Charles but most people call me Charlie
but there are still people that call me
Charles if they're being really formal
it's not so much a continuity problem as
it is them sort of like bending over
backwards just a little bit because the
tone of the Captain Marvel movie was a
little bit lighter speaking of tone
number seven why did Nick Fury pump up
how he lost his eye during Captain
America Winter Soldier so much if it was
gonna wind up being used for a joke
during the Captain Marvel movie most
likely answer for this is that the
Russos were making a much darker more
serious political thriller movie Winter
Soldier was away darker movie so the
Nick Fury character was written to be
much darker during that everything about
him was more hardcore so the way he lost
his eye was written as if it were a
really hardcore moment in his backstory
but because the Captain Marvel movie
needed a much fresher more comedic Nick
Fury to balance out Captain Marvel's
more stoic character everything about
Nick Fury was written to be more comedic
had Captain Marvel been a really dark
political thriller movie just like
Winter Soldier then we probably would
have seen him lose his eye in some
really gruesome fight but again I think
it's just a tone thing they just wanted
it to be a lighter film in general so
number six what happened to goose the
cat after the events of the Captain
Marvel movie after he puked the
tesseract back up even though this
comedic version of Nick Fury in the past
seemingly was a cat person that was also
a bit of a joke people were surprised by
Nick very cat person he seems so
hardcore in present day after goose
puked the tesseract up he took the
tesseract back to project Pegasus so
they could continue studying it he also
probably took goose the cat back to
project Pegasus where he had been living
for this whole time since Marvel died
the only reason that he was keeping him
as a pet so to speak are making a look
like it was his pet was to keep an eye
on the tesseract which he apparently did
not tell Coulson about because Coulson
asked about the tesseract and nickfear
is like I'm sure it'll resurface at some
point and just looks over at goosed the
cat sitting on his little cat bed we
don't know how long the floor can race
lives but I'm
assuming that unless we see him in
avengers endgame he's since died of old
age and if Captain Marvel still has a
goose cat in the Captain Marvel sequel
it will probably be a new cat not the
same one so obvious next question number
five will goose the cat appeared during
Avengers endgame and I say probably not
but number four will Maria Rambo or
Monica Rambeau show up in present day
during Avengers endgame and will Monica
Rambeau get her comic book powers in
present day she be in her late 20s
pretty prime age for a new actor to come
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but I'm guessing that they probably
won't show back up again until the
Captain Marvel sequel and because her
relationship with Maria Rambo was so
strong even though she'd be much much
older in present day maybe she's a
colonel or a general or something like
that but I do think that they will come
back during the Captain Marvel sequel
there were too many very obvious set up
lines of dialogue and foreshadowing for
Monica Rambo's character that she would
eventually become something really great
for her to not come back in the future 3
even bigger one will Marvel bring back
the scrolls for Secret Invasion movie
because they were not super evil during
the Captain Marvel movie it was a big
swerve on their comic book characters
kevin Baggies official statements were
they they wanted to undercut people's
expectations of the scrolls they wanted
to not do the super obvious thing but
the way he explained Secret Invasion in
the future is is that he said just like
any other space based race that you
would encounter in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there are good scrolls that we
met during the Captain Marvel movie
there are also evil scrolls that would
use their abilities to do really bad
things so that was him sort of winking
saying yes we will see in the future but
I think that they wouldn't do Secret
Invasion unless they were going to do it
as a big Avengers film which would be
Avengers 5 or Avengers 6 sometime in the
next several years we can talk about
those other future Avengers movies
because the Fox Disney deal is supposed
to close next week which means they get
all the x-men and all the Fantastic Four
IP which means that at some point one of
those big Avengers films will be the
merging of some of that IP and the
crossing characters over but that's way
away down the road so don't worry too
much about that right now
number two why didn't it fury call
Captain Marvel during the first Avengers
movie when there was a full-blown
Chitauri invasion of Earth in New York
this is where
get into a little bit of back bending
Kevin Feige official statement was is
that well it's because it was only
supposed to be a measure of last resort
if there was no other option and at the
time Nick Fury was enacting the Avengers
initiative forming the team for the
first time so had they lost at the end
of that movie then Nick Fury would have
called him but that would have been a
bummer way to start out the Avengers
franchise very first movie first time
ever seen them together on screen boom
they get their asses handed to them the
other video that I did about the Captain
Marvel scenes during this moment here
where they're meeting directly addresses
that why weren't you here before we
could have used you so I'll link that
video at the end of this number one
though obvious big question that
everyone's had since seeing the latest
Avengers endgame trailer
what will captain Marvel's role in
Avengers endgame be what are they gonna
use her for if they set her up to be so
powerful right now based on the footage
we've seen in the reports from the other
scenes that they've screened mostly
space based storyline stuff early
prediction like assembling a giant space
Armada with a reformed version of the
Nova Corps or other space based races
anyone she can get to fight the shatori
which they are bringing back for the
movie so the Chitauri sort of like a
bland space based evil villain race you
obviously would need someone to fight
that what did Captain Marvel do for the
last 10 or so minutes of her film she
just spent all that time in space
blowing up ronan ships so that's
probably what she's gonna spend most of
her time doing during avengers endgame
but yes of course I think that she's
probably gonna go toe-to-toe with Thanos
the more interesting twist though like I
said would be is she lost because Kevin
Feige said we won't learn about her
weakness until Avengers end game post
all your big Avengers endgame questions
in the comments and what will happen is
is they'll be more Marvel happening the
next couple of days so while you wait
for everything click here to rewatch the
avengers endgame trailer a billion more
times and all my Easter eggs and click
here to learn about all those extra
Captain Marvel scenes from Avengers and
games that do not appear in the trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]